und jetzt das heute journal
Ostern ist für Christen das Wichtigste
das höchste Fest im Jahr und wie jedes
Jahr sprach der Papst am Ostersonntag
sein Segen Obi
zudem rief er die gesamte internationale
Gemeinschaft dazu auf ihre Herzen zu
öffnen
damit sie sich für die Beendigung von
Kriegen einsetzt die die Welt mit Blut
beflecken
wir alle sollten uns beeilen Konflikte
und Spaltungen zu überwinden
ein Appell an uns alle quasi und
insbesondere an die Staatenlenker dieser
Welt und damit erst einmal einen schönen
guten Abend und frohe Ostern das Problem
mit dem Appell an die Staatenlenker er
dürfte sie wenig interessieren weder
einen Bacher alassat noch einen Wladimir
Putin oder einen
letzterer schickte heute eine Art
Warnung an die westliche Welt und an
Taiwan das chinesische Militärs
simultierte simulierte bei Manövern
präzisionschläge gegen Zitat
schlüsselziele auf der Insel Taiwan und
in den umliegenden Gewässern Kampfjets
Bomber Bodentruppen alles soll dabei
gewesen sein
und alle schauen alarmiert wie irritiert
zu Japan geht allerdings noch einen
Schritt weiter und rüstet gerade auch
wegen der geografischen Lage und dem
Wissen dass im Indopazifik die Macht
Bestrebungen mehrerer Länder
Aufeinandertreffen massiv auf davon
betroffen sind insbesondere die
Militärbasen die sich auf den
japanischen Mann sei Inseln befinden und
eine davon ist amami ushima dort hat
unsere Korrespondentin Elisabeth Schmidt
ziemlich seltener Einblicke erhalten
die Militärgebäude auf amami sind grün
angestrichen sie sollen sich bestmöglich
in die Landschaft einfügen die Insel
zählt zum unesco-welt Naturerbe das
Gelände war ein Golfplatz bis in die
Regierung aufkaufte und zum
Militärstützpunkt umfunktionierte stolz
wird er uns präsentiert heute trainieren
die japanischen
Selbstverteidigungsstreitkräfte hier für
einen Angriff Chinas mit modernster
flugabwehrraketentechniken brauchen wir
Raketen um sie auszuschalten auch
Attacken aus der Luft können wir auf
diese Weise abwehren unsere
übungsszenarius Spielen durch das genau
das passieren könnte
die Streitkräfte auf Armani trainieren
auch regelmäßig mit Truppen aus den USA
das soll vor allem China und seine
Kriegsflotte abschrecken zahlenmäßig die
größte der Welt dass die Spannungen im
Indopazifik zunehmend wird auch auf
Armani ganz genau beobachtet
hallo
taiwan ist nur knapp 110 km vom
südlichsten Teil unserer Provinz Okinawa
entfernt das ist nicht weit von hier
natürlich betrifft uns Chinas Macht
streben immens
Japans Antwort der Verteidigungshaushalt
soll bis 2027 massiv steigen verglichen
zu heute hätte Japan dann den
drittgrößten Rüstungsetat der Welt nach
den USA und China das Umdenken in Tokio
ausgelöst durch den Krieg in der Ukraine
Russlands Invasion war so ein Schock
Russland das über Atomwaffen verfügt
marschiert in seinem Nachbarland ein
hier in Japan hatten viele das Gefühl
wenn wir die russische Invasion einfach
so hinnehmen dann könnten bald auch
andere Länder von Tyrannen überfallen
werden
auf amami trainieren Japans Soldaten
inzwischen nicht mehr nur wie bislang
reine Landesverteidigung sondern auch
Gegenschläge
hierofumium Mura macht das große Sorgen
der Reis Pharma befürchtet Japans
Aufrüstung könnte China weiter
provozieren
es muss nur ein kleiner Zusammenstoß
passieren auf See vielleicht auch nur
aus Versehen das macht mir am meisten
Angst dass ein winzig kleiner
Zwischenfall einen Krieg auslösen konnte
mit der Kriegsgefahr leben sie auf amami
jeden Tag zwischen Traumstränden und
Truppenübungen
die USA wir haben es gerade gehört sind
dort auch involviert müssen aber gerade
akut einen anderen Brand löschen löschen
und herausfinden wer ihn gelegt bzw wer
ihn geliebt hat es geht um geheime
Dokumente die im Internet veröffentlicht
wurden und die zahlreiche sensible
Informationen enthalten sollen zum
Beispiel über westliche Militärhilfe an
die Ukraine zur Streitkräften und
Taktiken sowohl das Pentagon als auch
das Justizministerium untersuchen die
Vorfälle MRT wissen
schon seit Kriegsbeginn liefern die USA
und ihre Verbündeten der Ukraine
wertvolle Informationen mit e8j-stars
Flugzeugen mit unbemannten Global Hawk
Drohnen und mit denen in extremer Höhe
fliegenden u2-maschinen aber all das ist
offenbar nur ein kleiner Ausschnitt aus
dem Arsenal von aufklärungswerkzeugen
der Alliierten erstmals werden in den
rund 100 Dokumenten nun bisher streng
geheime Details bekannt verbreitet über
Social Media sie bieten zwar nur einen
Schnappschuss über die Lage im Krieg
Anfang März mit einer Fülle von
taktischen Informationen über das
Geschehen an der Front aber die Papiere
die zum Teil auch dem ZDF vorliegen
enthalten Hinweise auf neue
Abhörmöglichkeiten der Kommunikation im
russischen Militärapparat bisher
unbekannte Methoden der Satelliten
Spionage wie das sogenannte
lapis-programm das wohl best gehütete
Geheimnis der us-luft Aufklärung
mit all dem kannten die USA offenbar die
Pläne Russlands für Luftangriffe auf die
Infrastruktur der Ukraine schon vor
ihrer Ausführung
in einem Papier konkrete Opfer Zahlen
auf russische und ukrainischer Seite die
dachzeile legt nahe dass es für den
us-militärstaat gefertigt wurde
möglicherweise für generalstaatschef
melee als Teil einer Präsentation für
Verbündete Anfang März im deutschen
Randstein
die Dokumente geben einen Eindruck wie
viel die USA täglich liefert das Weiße
Haus will das immer runter spielen weil
der Präsident immer sagte sind keine
Kriegsteilnehmer drücken keinen Abzug
schicken keine Truppen aber man sieht
wir tun alles unterhalb davon
das Pentagon begrenzt für Verbündete nun
massiv den Zugang zu solchen
Geheiminformationen das
Justizministerium sucht nach den
Urhebern des Datenlecks der Schaden
wächst über Social Media werden auch
verfälschte Versionen der Dokumente für
Propaganda Zwecke verbreitet noch ist
unklar ob und wie das
Vertrauensverhältnis zwischen den USA
und der Ukraine durch das bekannt werden
der Militär Geheimnisse belastet wird
ja und die Ukraine bezeichnet sie als
Fälschung russische Reaktionen sind
widersprüchlich manche Dokumente sollen
und wir haben ja gerade auch im Beitrag
gehört im Nachhinein manipuliert worden
sein lass uns das ganze einordnen von El
matersen hallo Emma erstmal Größe nach
Washington bei allen Unsicherheiten und
ja auch Unklarheiten rund um die liegst
wie brisant sind Sie denn noch
ja ist schon ein Schlag für die
ukrainischen Streitkräfte denn ihre
ganzen aufmach-pläne aber auch wann
kommen welche neuen Waffensysteme an
welche Munition das ist erstmal
öffentlich geworden und das sät
natürlich Misstrauen nicht nur zwischen
Ukraine und den USA sondern auch anderen
Bündnispartnern die ja auch ihre
aufklärungserkenntnisse beigetragen
haben zudem und das alles kommt in
geballter Form auf einmal an die
Öffentlichkeit des stellt natürlich die
große Frage wer da Sand ins Getriebe
streuen will das ist noch völlig offen
das muss ermittelt werden aber ganz
offenbar ist es für diesen Krieg
sicherlich für die Ukraine nicht
nützlich dass das passiert dann da noch
mal konkreter nachgefragt welchen
Einfluss können denn diese
Veröffentlichungen nun auf das
Kriegsgeschehen in der Ukraine haben
ja nun sind die Daten ja eigentlich
schon vier Wochen alter so vielleicht
nicht unmittelbar auf das
Kriegsgeschehen jetzt in den nächsten
Tagen und Wochen aber dadurch dass
Russland jetzt genauer weiß wie die
Verbündeten aufklären welche
satellitenwerkzeuge Lauschangriffe sie
benutzen können Sie versuchen diese
elektronisch zu stören zu unterlaufen
können nach Quellen in den eigenen
Reihen suchen menschlichen Quellen und
das macht es natürlich sehr sehr
schwierig das heißt am Ende könnte die
gut geölte Maschinerie der bestmöglichen
Unterstützung für die Ukraine ins
Stocken kommen und damit möglicherweise
auch die Offensive der Ukraine in diesem
Frühjahr zumindestens mal beeinträchtigt
werden was dann die russische Seite
Freunde dürfte immer vielen Dank für
deine Einordnung
und mit dem Krieg in der Ukraine
beginnen auch deine Nachrichten Heinz ja
bei einem russischen Raketenangriff auf
die Großstadt saporisch ja im Südosten
der Ukraine wurde ein Wohnhaus getroffen
und nach Angaben der örtlichen Behörden
sind dabei ein Vater und seine
elfjährige Tochter getötet worden die
Mutter oder lebensgefährlich verletzt
unterdessen sind 31 ukrainische Kinder
aus Russland in ihre Heimat
zurückgekehrt eine ukrainische nicht
Regierungsorganisation hat das nach
eigenen Angaben zusammen mit Eltern
erreicht
unter dem Eindruck dieses Krieges und
weitere Krisen weltweit standen auch die
Osterfeiern der Kirchen in Deutschland
der Vorsitzende der katholischen
Bischofskonferenz Georg betzing sagte
die Auferstehung Jesu die an Ostern
gefeiert werde setze der Eskalation von
Krisen und Gewalt eine Eskalation des
Lebens und der Liebe entgegen die
Ratsvorsitzende der Evangelischen
kirche- sagte Ostern sei eine Gegenrede
Gottes gegen alles was festgefahren und
ohne Aussicht erscheine
Bundesarbeitsminister Heil rechnet mit
einer deutlichen Anhebung des
Mindestlohns zum kommenden Jahr die
zuständige Kommission werde im Sommer
einen Vorschlag machen Heil verwies auf
die hohe Inflation und auf die
Tarifabschlüsse die sich dann zum ersten
Januar in einer mindestlohnerhöhung über
die aktuell geltenden zwölf Euro hinaus
niederschlagen würden
der Großbrand in einem Gewerbeareal in
Hamburg ist unter Kontrolle mehrere
Lagerhallen waren in den frühen
Morgenstunden in Flammen aufgegangen es
entstand eine große Rauchwolke die Stadt
einwärts zog und es galten in Teilen
Hamburgs den Tag über entsprechende
Warnungen der Feuerwehr die Ursache für
den Brand ist noch nicht geklärt
zum Sport an diesem Sonntag in der
Fußball-Bundesliga heute drei Spiele
Borussia Mönchengladbach gewinnt gegen
Wolfsburg 2:0 Bochum unterliegt
Stuttgart zwei zu drei und Hoffenheim
geht mit zwei zu null gegen Schalke als
Sieger vom Platz Schalke ist jetzt auf
dem letzten Tabellenplatz und am Abend
war die Auslosung zum Halbfinale im
DFB-Pokal Anfang Mai so sieht es aus
Freiburg spielt gegen Leipzig und
Stuttgart gegen Eintracht Frankfurt
und jetzt die Wetteraussichten morgen am
Vormittag im Osten einige
Hochnebelfelder sonst zunächst viel
Sonne später von Westen hier mehr Wolken
und gegen Abend auf kommende Regen bei
lebhaftem Südwind 14 bis 19 Grad die
weiteren Aussichten unbeständig mit
Regen Gewittern aber auch etwas Sonne
dazu sehr windig und wieder kühler
Donnerstag nur noch 7 bis 13 Grad
schlicht könnte man jetzt sagen wir
machen jetzt einfach mal weiter mit
einem Romantik Drama es geht um den
neuen Film von Sam Mendes und so weiter
weniger schlicht und auch viel passender
ist aber wenn Sie auf das Genre stehen
dann gehen sie rein in diesen neuen Film
des Oscar-Preisträgers empire of Light
ist ein Tanz zwischen mehreren Welten
mentaler Gesundheit Rassismus sexuelle
Ausbeutung britische Gesellschaft unter
Fetscher und und und und und dadurch
vielleicht auch ein bisschen zu
vollgepackt dieser Film aber das findet
jedenfalls Nadja nasser dennoch
sehenswert
es ist noch immer ein magischer Ort das
alte Kino Empire in einer englischen
Kleinstadt am Meer auch wenn es 1981
seine besten Jahre schon hinter sich hat
hier arbeitet Hillary seit Jahren kämpft
sie mit einer manischen Depression
schleppt sich mehr schlecht als recht
durch den Alltag
[Musik]
wie fühlen sie sich im Allgemeinen
bis eines Tages ein neuer Mitarbeiter
ins Kino kommt
hallo Steven ist als schwarzer junger
Mann ein Außenseiter in der englischen
Gesellschaft Hillary und er kommen sich
näher
oh mein Gott er war wirklich wunderschön
das ist ja noch sie heißt sie findet mit
ihm die liebevollste Beziehung ihres
Lebens ihre Gefühle füreinander sind
echt und es spielt für sie keine Rolle
wo sie herkommen oder wie alt Sie sind
sie sind Seelenverwandte und das ist
wunderschön
für die beiden beginnt eine kurze Zeit
des Glücks in der kleinen Welt des
Empire Kinos findet das ungleiche
Liebespaar seinen Freiraum aber die
Realität der Kleinstadt sieht anders aus
immer wieder wird Steven rassistisch
angegriffen
und Hillary wird schmerzlich klar Steven
muss von hier fortgehen um glücklich
werden zu können
niemand gibt dir das Leben dass du dir
wünschst du selbst musst es gestalten
hier wird das nicht gehen
ist gut für Regisseur Sam Mendes ist es
der persönlichste Film seiner Karriere
mit empire of light bringt der
Oscar-Preisträger ein autobiografisch
inspiriertes Kleinod auf die Leinwand so
verarbeitet er die bipolare Störung
seiner Mutter in der Figur von Hillary
einfühlsam gespielt von Olivia Coleman
und die frühen 80er Jahre waren die
prägenden Jahre für mich damals habe ich
meine ersten politischen Ansichten
geformt es war die Zeit von Fetscher von
Massenarbeitslosigkeit und rassistischen
Spannungen
empire of Light ist ein packendes
Gesellschaftsdrama ein bewegender
Liebesfilm und eine wunderschöne Hommage
an die Magie des Kinos
[Musik]
und nach
Stevens wieder ein Regisseur ganz
offenbar der sich Filme der eigenen
Kindheit und Mutter wird mit ganz
spannend und interessant
das war es aber jetzt erstmal von uns
aber doch der Hinweis auf 0:15 Uhr und
die nächste heute Express das wie gesagt
was von uns machen sie es gut wo auch
immer sie sind schönen Abend noch
[Musik]